Trascrizione: Claudia Bottigelli
Revisore: Sara Pasini
Era il 2017 e mi trovavo in
un letto di ospedale.
Mi avevano appena salvato la vita.
L’unica cosa che volevo fare
in quel momento era ritornare
a fare la mia vita precedente,
a fare il mio lavoro precedente.
Il problema era che era la mia vita,
il mio lavoro ad avermi portato
in quel letto di ospedale.
E si dice che è nei momenti più bassi,
più bui che nascono le migliori idee,
le migliori opportunità.
Ma io in quel momento non vedevo nulla,
vedevo nero.
Solo a distanza di qualche anno capisco
che anche per me in quel letto di ospedale
stava nascendo qualcosa,
qualcosa di nuovo.
E oggi ringrazio che quell’episodio
sia capitato all’inizio
della mia carriera professionale
perché ha cambiato totalmente
il modo in cui oggi conduco
la mia vita e il lavoro che faccio.
Oggi vivo a Fuerteventura, un’isola
in cui tutto scorre molto lentamente
e lavoro in uno dei luoghi
più frenetici che oggi esistono.
Il mondo delle criptovalute
e del Metaverso.
Immaginate il Metaverso
come un universo digitale.
E in questo universo digitale,
chiamato Metaverso,
ci sono tanti piccoli pianeti
anch’essi digitali.
Ogni pianeta ha la sua popolazione
come ogni pianeta digitale
ha la sua community online.
E ogni popolazione,
come ogni community online,
ha la sua lingua, la sua cultura
e la sua arte.
Tutto ciò che accade nel Metaverso
per me è molto più importante
di ciò che accade nella mia vita reale.
Le relazioni che io ho nel Metaverso
sono più importanti
delle relazioni che io ho nella
mia vita reale a Fuerteventura.
E probabilmente sarà così
per molti di noi.
E se questo può spaventarvi,
può farvi ricordare Matrix per esempio,
beh vi devo dire che è già realtà
da più di vent’anni.
Noi da più di vent’anni viviamo già
in una sorta di universo digitale.
La prima cosa che facciamo al mattino,
anziché dare un bacio
alla persona accanto a noi nel letto
o al nostro cane,
guardiamo il telefono. La maggior parte di
noi passa le successive 8-10 ore
davanti ad un monitor digitale a lavorare
e poi la sera, non contenti,
accendiamo magari anche la televisione
per informarci o per intrattenerci.
Le persone nate come me negli anni ’90
conoscono bene questo universo digitale.
Ci siamo cresciuti
in un universo digitale.
Siamo la prima generazione
di nativi digitali.
che non ha imparato dai libri di scuola
ma ha imparato dai tutorial di YouTube.
Siamo la prima generazione che quando ha
trovato la soluzione ad un problema
l’ha condivisa con il resto del mondo,
con degli sconosciuti.
Siamo la prima generazione di persone che
ha cercato persone affini a noi online
e solo successivamente le ha incontrate
nella vita reale.
E anch’io all’età di 14 anni ho cominciato
a condividere online,
come immagino molti di voi,
le mie passioni.
E quello per me è stato
il mio matrimonio con la creatività.
Io e la creatività ancora oggi
siamo sposati.
È un matrimonio bellissimo il nostro,
con degli alti e dei bassi.
E nei punti più bassi la creatività
mi ha portato in quel letto di ospedale.
Ed è lì che io per la prima volta
ho sentito parlare di criptovalute.
Mi sono cominciato ad interessare al mondo
delle criptovalute.
E come ogni persona che approccia
questo nuovo mondo
quasi tutti lo approcciano per
fini speculativi,
come fosse una scommessa dove
poter vincere un jackpot milionario.
Ma, oltre ad essere una falsa credenza,
è solamente la punta dell’iceberg
della rivoluzione che
le criptovalute invece portano.
E così ho passato i successivi anni
a cercare di capire come
trovare un’intersezione fra questo mondo
così razionale, mondo numerico
con un mondo invece così emotivo,
soggettivo
come il mondo creativo e artistico.
Fino al momento in cui ho incontrato per
la prima volta gli NFT,
i non-fungible tokens.
In italiano beni non fungibili,
una parola estremamente complessa
per descrivere qualcosa invece
di estremamente semplice.
Immaginate di scambiare vostra moglie e
vostro marito o il vostro cane
con quello di qualcun altro.
Potrà andarvi bene, potrà andarvi male.
Magari avrete un marito o una moglie
migliore, ma sicuramente non sarà
lo stesso marito o la stessa moglie
perché sono beni non fungibili.
Anche l’arte è un bene non fungibile.
Un quadro è un bene non fungibile,
una scultura è un bene non fungibile.
Ma anche la fotografia
è un bene non fungibile
perché se la fotografia è stampata,
firmata dall’artista e numerata
la numero 1 vale di più della numero 2
e quindi è non fungibile.
Che cos’è quindi un bene fungibile?
Beh un bene fungibile per eccellenza
sono le banconote.
Supponiamo che io abbia una banconota
da 10 euro e voi pure.
La mia è più stropicciata della vostra,
la vostra ha un numero seriale
sicuramente diverso dalla mia.
Eppure, se noi ce le scambiamo,
abbiamo ancora una banconota
che ha lo stesso valore: 10 euro.
Noi per convenzione accettiamo
che il denaro,
in questo caso la banconota da 10 euro,
mantenga il suo valore
nonostante cambi magari
in piccoli dettagli.
Scopriamo quindi che la maggior parte
delle cose intorno a noi è non fungibile.
E i non-fungible tokens,
beni non fungibili digitali,
non sono altro che immagini,
video, canzoni digitali,
con però una piccola peculiarità:
al loro interno hanno
una riga di codice invisibile.
Supponiamo di prendere un’immagine
e all’interno di questa immagine c’è una
riga di codice invisibile che dice
che ogni qual volta che l’immagine
passa di mano in mano,
diventa più grande o piccola
oppure cambia colore.
Però questo è un esempio fine a se stesso.
Sforziamoci un po’ di più e proviamo ad
ad immaginare invece
di prendere un’immagine e inserire
al suo interno una riga di codice
che dice che ogni volta
che l’immagine viene venduta
e passa di proprietario in proprietario,
di collezionista in collezionista,
il 10% della vendita finisca all’artista.
Si chiama royalties ed è qualcosa che
nel web, negli ultimi 20 anni,
abbiamo completamente dimenticato.
Ma l'industria creativa si è sempre
basata sulle royalties.
E allora questo apre un ventaglio di nuove
opportunità per tutti i creativi.
Supponiamo di prendere il vostro musicista
preferito.
Ah, voi amate la sua musica e, come voi,
altre decine di migliaia di persone.
Però il vostro musicista preferito non ha
ancora un'etichetta discografica disposta
a produrgli il suo nuovo album,
la sua arte.
Però voi lo amate.
Ascoltate la sua musica quando
andate al lavoro in macchina,
quando fate la doccia
e quando fate l’amore.
Il musicista ha bisogno di denaro
per produrre la sua arte.
Voi volete supportare un artista
che pensate che in futuro
possa scalare le classifiche
e riempire gli stadi.
Il musicista emette un NFT: può essere
il provino di una sua canzone,
una sua fotografia, un suo video,
non importa.
L’importante è che all’interno
di questo NFT
ci sia questa riga di codice invisibile.
Voi comprate l’NFT e il musicista riceve
i fondi per produrre la sua arte.
Voi avete accesso a una community
esclusiva di persone
che come voi hanno supportato l’artista.
Avete accesso a contenuti esclusivi,
online e anche nella vita reale magari.
Potrete andare alle prove
di registrazione del suo album
o alle prove prima di un concerto.
Perché voi siete i primi supporter di
questo artista.
E supponiamo che l’album musicale
creato grazie ai vostri fondi
scali le classifiche delle
piattaforme musicali
e le persone comincino
ad ascoltare le sue canzoni.
La canzone comincia a venir
riprodotta in radio
e le persone che si sposano
la utilizzano al loro matrimonio.
Ogni qual volta la canzone è riprodotta,
le royalties non vanno solamente
all’artista, ma vanno alla community,
a voi che avete supportato l’artista
dal giorno zero.
Questa cosa si può applicare a tante
industrie creative:
all’industria cinematografica,
all’industria delle arti visive,
all’industria editoriale.
La domanda che un creator, un artista
si deve fare nel 2021 non è più:
“Come posso trarre il maggior valore
dalla mia community?”
L’unica domanda che un artista si deve
fare nel 2021 è “Come posso dare
il maggior valore alla mia community?”
Valore artistico e valore economico.
E allora in questi piccoli pianeti creati
da artisti e supportati da community
nascono delle nuove economie, in cui
gli incentivi sono allineati fra community
e creators e solo così si possono
raggiungere grandi obiettivi.
Siamo di fronte ad una nuova rivoluzione
e gli artisti sono fra i pionieri
di questa nuova tecnologia.
E noi esseri umani nell’antichità ci
sedevamo attorno al fuoco per raccontarci
delle storie, come la storia che io
ho raccontato oggi a voi.
Ed è proprio intorno al fuoco
che abbiamo creato le prime tribù
e le prime forme di società
per come le conosciamo oggi.
Secondo me la blockchain, le criptovalute
e gli NFT sono il nuovo fuoco digitale
dove sederci intorno per creare
una società digitale
migliore di quella attuale.
Oggi è il miglior momento nella
storia per essere un artista.
Grazie mille.